what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
only have
two episodes left of the falcon and the
winter soldier
it's been a great series so far it's a
shame that we only get six episodes
however sebastian stan did recently say
that he would do anything to do a second
season
so you never really know this may not
actually be the end
but until we get a confirmation we'll
act like this is the end and even though
we only have two episodes left we still
have
a lot to unpack there's the mysterious
power broker that has yet to come into
play
also will he actually come into play or
will this kind of be like
a benefactor situation from the ant-man
and the wasp and then we have the
mysterious cameo that is supposed to
appear in episode 5 and no
it is not the same cameo that the power
broker is this has been confirmed by
different sources
we also know that sam is supposed to be
getting captain america shield and using
it at one point in time but he has yet
to do that
but thanks to a leaked video we have it
seems like we know when
exactly he's going to be getting that
shield and of course there is still talk
and there is still a chance that old man
steve rogers good old captain america
could still appear
in the falcon and the winter soldier
series so a lot to break down but before
we get started a quick reminder about my
captain america falcon and the winter
soldier shield giveaway
just sub to me and my other channel
cosmic culture for a chance to enter
details in the description down below so
a big question that everybody has been
asking
before we even got the first episode for
the falcon and the winter soldier is
is steve rogers going to come back are
we going to see
old man steve in the falcon and the
winter soldier and marvel has done an
incredibly great job at being super
vague about whether or not steve rogers
is
dead or if he simply went back to his
own timeline or if he is just chilling
in the normal timeline but nobody really
knows it's him
this is a story that didn't really have
a definitive ending
yes steve finally got his dance with
peggy carter but then he returned to the
main timeline at the end
what happened after that that we don't
know and it is something that fans would
like an answer to
so the answer to the question could
steve rogers still appear in the falcon
in the winter soldier is
yes especially if you consider where sam
is at right now in the series
everything he's going through all of the
struggles that he's facing
about the shield and what it represents
and means now is the perfect time for
captain america to show up and give him
a little pep talk
however it doesn't really seem like the
story of isaiah bradley is done yet
which is good because in the comics he
has a big
big story a very complicated story and
it looks like his story in the mcu is
pretty similar
and based off of the mid-season trailer
that we got from marvel studios
yesterday it does look like sam does
return
to talk to isaiah and it does look like
he goes and talks to him about what the
shield
actually means recently sam has been
debating on whether or not he should
have destroyed the shield
rather than giving it up to the
government and this conflict i believe
is going to lead him back to isaiah
since isaiah was the first black captain
america but was also thrown in jail it
would make sense that sam would seek his
opinion on whether or not he thought the
shield was good or bad and i think this
scene is definitely going to happen but
will we get a scene where we see steve
rogers talking to sam about what the
shield means
even though this story is focused on sam
and bucky they both were the best
friends of steve
rogers and steve has already been a
pretty powerful presence
in all of the episodes even though he
hasn't really been in any we've seen
pictures of him
we've heard his voice they've made jokes
about him being on the moon
but is he still there if he's alive and
existing
in the normal timeline that we know the
one that he came back to at the end of
avengers in-game the main timeline then
there's a pretty good chance that we
could probably see him now of course he
has to be alive and he has to be
existing
in the main timeline if neither of those
are true then unfortunately we aren't
going to see him so don't get your hopes
up
too much but it is a possibility now as
far as that conflict about the shield
that sam is having
we've yet to really see him use the
shield and we've seen him use it plenty
of time in the trailers
and in the trailer that we got yesterday
we do see sam and bucky
approaching john walker after the ending
of episode 4
and it looks like they're going to fight
him for the shield but as i mentioned in
my video yesterday i don't think they
get it
they either fight and he beats them and
he keeps the shield or they make an
agreement to go on and fight the flax
masters together either way john walker
is walking away with that shield
and the reason we know that is because
of this leaked video
this is a scene that we've never seen
before and john walker still has the
shield and he's fighting the flag
smashers and it looks like he's kind of
kicking their butts
now who knows what's going to happen
here will jon actually become the main
enemy and the flax masters actually get
some sense talked into them
who really knows but it doesn't look
like sam is going to be getting that
shield until the very last episode
perhaps at the end of the very last
episode in fact i wouldn't be surprised
if that's kind of the final scene
sam finally taking up the shield and him
and bucky used it together
to fight a bunch of different people the
flag smashers john walker
the power broker whoever they need to
take down and then i think at the end of
the falcon and the winter soldier
we will have our new captain america who
of course will be
sam the person who should be captain
america because
the old captain america gave him the
shield now as i mentioned there's been a
lot of talk about this mysterious cameo
that is supposed to come in episode 5.
and there are some insiders claiming
that they know the actor that is going
to be playing the mysterious character
but they don't know the role
however some of them like charles murphy
have said that this mysterious character
is not the power broker which means the
power broker still could be
thunderbolt ross and the more and more
we think about this the more and more
this kind of makes sense
thunderbolt ross is the person
responsible for the sokovia accords and
we know that he
definitely likes to enforce it telling
roadie in avengers infinity war to
arrest steve rogers natasha romanov
sam wilson the scarlet witch and vision
but this also means he is the person
that has the power to pardon people
and as we know sam and bucky have both
been pardoned but
sharon carter has not and the power
broker is definitely somebody in power
and we know he wants the serum and
thunderbolt ross has
always wanted the super soldier serum
that's his thing
in secret he resurrected the super
soldier program
now known as the weapons plus program as
we saw in the incredible hulk
so he has the power to pardon people but
he also wants the serum and we know that
sharon carter is working very closely
with the power
broker however we know that sharon
carter is a good person so why would she
be working with the power broker
and why was she so upset when dr nagle
the person creating the new
improved perfect super soldier serum was
killed
perhaps she was trying to get some super
soldier serum for
ross this could be the way that she was
going to get pardoned and be able to
return home
that could be the deal that thunderbolt
ross threw at her get me some serum and
i'll pardon you unfortunately now it's
gone so how else could she get pardoned
well she could join his thunderbolts
team
the same goes with elena bulova we know
that ross is going to be after black
widow and her sister in the black widow
film he could offer her a deal as well
to get pardoned and that deal could be
join his team do his work and the same
goes for zemo
demo is now out of prison and ross is
not going to like that but again
could offer a deal join my team and i'll
pardon you he is a person who has power
to do this
and he's also a very shady and corrupt
person as well so i would not be
surprised
in the slightest if he is the power
broker but on the other hand knowing
marvel i also wouldn't be surprised if
we never see who the power broker
actually is
we'll just have to wait and see but as
far as the mystery character is
concerned
we do know a little bit about this
person now sadly i have to say don't get
your hopes up for a character like
wolverine or any crazy huge x-men or
fantastic four member or anybody just
really crazy out there the showrunner
for the show has already said
that this is a very grounded character
we also have found out that it's
somebody who is not yet in the mcu
and will not be in any upcoming projects
and of course the x-men
are coming in the future this has
already been confirmed by kevin feige
himself
so that pretty much takes the x-men off
the table a big theory was that it's
actually going to be
chadwick boseman wakanda and the dora
milage have played a pretty big role in
the past couple of episodes and this did
film before chadwick passed away however
the marvel team has recently came out
and stated that no it is not going to be
chadwick boseman so that's off the table
now we did learn that this is actually
going to be an academy award-winning
actor or actress one that a lot of
people according to slash film would
never have thought would be in the mcu
now as far as the actual character is
concerned we don't really know
i don't really think it's going to be a
huge character and a part of me thinks
that it actually is going to be chris
evans
as captain america and marvel's just
kind of messing with us and trying to
throw us off right now
but if they are telling the truth then
my guess is just as good as yours
let me know who you think this
mysterious character is going to be
in the comments down below and of course
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell because if i find
anything else out i'll be sure to do a
video on it let me know all your
thoughts about this video in the
comments down below
thoughts about the power broker thoughts
about isaiah bradley thoughts about
old man captain america returning and
who you think this mysterious character
could be
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram twitter and tick tock
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof